[Music]
Aysen palace is a j/s with movieclips
here with some premature Oscar
predictions now the Oscars were earlier
this month but we feel we've heard
enough of the early buzz to go ahead and
take a stab at predicting what's gonna
win next year so let's get going
the nominees for Best Picture will be
big eyes is the latest film by Tim
Burton Foxcatcher starring Steve Carell
gone girl this is David Fincher adapting
the bestseller novel the grand Budapest
hotel the latest and greatest from Wes
Anderson the imitation game starring
Benedict Cumberbatch inherent vice the
latest film by PT Anderson and my
personal most anticipated film of the
year into the woods this is gonna be a
big Hollywood musical with lots of stars
and her stellar Christopher Nolan's
gonna take us to space I'd have cups
terrence malick used to average a film
per decade now he's turning them out
every year and unbroken I predict that
the Oscar is gonna go to unbroken this
is Angelina Jolie's sophomore effort as
a director and as the true story of
Lewis's amorini who was an Olympic
runner and then was a powa in Japan
during World War two I think it has all
the trappings of something that the
Academy is gonna fall in love with for
best achievement and direction the
nominees are Angelina Jolie for unbroken
David Fincher gone girl PT Anderson
inherent vice Wes Anderson for the grand
Budapest hotel and of course Christopher
Nolan for interstellar again I fill this
is going to go to unbroken for Angelina
Jolie the nominees for Best Actor will
be Benedict Cumberbatch for the
imitation game Jack O'Connell for
unbroken Joaquin Phoenix for inherent
vice the Makana sense will continue with
interstellar and Steve Carell for
Foxcatcher the winner will be Steve
Carell this is something completely out
of his will house the transformation
that he took on to be the schizophrenic
man is at
mesmerising from what we've seen so far
the nominees for best actress will be
amy adams for big eyes meryl streep of
course were into the woods Nicole Kidman
for grace of monoco Reese Witherspoon
for wild and Rosamund Pike for the
titular role in gone girl and the Oscar
is going to go to Nicole Kidman for
grace of monoco this is a biopic about
Grace Kelly and one of the most
important chapters of her life there's
lots of political overtones here she's
gonna win it alright guys those are my
predictions for the major categories of
next year's Oscars comment below to take
me to task on any of my predictions or
share any of yours but it looks like
we're gonna have to wait until next year
to know if I was right for movieclips
this is Jay S thanks for watching
[Music]
[Music]